Burt are you still are meeting people
after shows TV theater shows you should
tell me how you've been able to do it
and not lose your mind and not and not
not do it because last weekend I was in
DC and I was like I don't want to be
touched by people right now I don't want
I don't want to do it I did not only get
touched people take their shirts off I
had one guy one time a Spokane takes his
shirt off and he grabs me I'm like bro
you were on fire he's like I got a
pretty bad fever I know you're sick and
he was like very sick am I gonna get
sick he goes probably I was like why are
you doing this he was all what I'm gonna
miss this for the life of you
kidding me
[Music]
I want to ask you about when you first
drank after sober October how good did
that feel and how bad did that feel the
next morning like how hard did you go
what did you do the first drink I had
you know it's crazy as I like I mean I
I'm just measuring this by last night's
last night wasn't the kind of drinking
that I disliked but like it's just I'm
on a plane and I'm just ordering
doubles after doubles after doubles and
I'm just like and I'm like oh about its
Mickey mill gene but but the right that
first weekend I drank it was all of a
sudden like a brand new it was like
being 18 again and drinking and going I
just need one drink and I'm feeling
tired I'm gonna go home and I was really
measured and then I flew home and I my
wife threw a birthday party for me and I
had a that was Sunday and so it was like
a full bender Sunday and then we did
sober October and I blacked out during
that podcast I have no recollection in
the last hour I don't I mean I remember
we all went to dinner I know that I paid
I have no idea what the bill was I don't
know if I tipped like it was like the
next morning and I said to Tommy I was
like I would have been equally as
surprised had I been chained in a
basement versus waking up in my bed both
of them I was like how the did this
happen
oh how often do you get that drunk not
often I mean I think so rocktober is I
mean we smoked a blunt I never smoked
blunt
I love blood I really enjoyed the blood
really fun but it was like we drank a
whole bottle of whiskey we drank a bunch
of beers we work we were trying to
benchpress
I think Rogan pulled his leg pulled a
muscle his leg we're trying to
benchpress 225 I'm 40 foot six
what am i benching three of me yeah and
so a little bit less of me after you've
been so sober and so clean it's like
you're Lou it's like you like you got so
clean and then it's like going backward
you know that feeling of like I did this
what's interesting is you know those
people that go I eliminated all food and
then slowly reintroduced things back
into my diet to figure out what
allergic to yes alcohol is directly
connected to my anxiety and I think I
always knew that but I didn't realize
how hand in hand what kissing cousins
alcohol and anxiety are because I was
getting on planes of flying stone sober
and being cool with it and having no
panic yeah but man the uneasiness that
alcohol does to my stomach I get to the
airport and I am like a mess yeah and
then I'm like well me the drink
to calm down yeah it's cycle yeah yeah
for sure it's genius I think it's
because I've been dabbling with the idea
of maybe drinking again and I'm just
like no don't do it it's so not worth it
and it's a depressant gonna flirt with
like something that's gonna make
literally makes you depressed you know
acid reflux
from drinking is so bad like I'll have
one glass of something it's like
immediately sleeping is the thing that I
value more than anything right now is I
slept so good during the month of
October I slept so good now here's a
difference I slept really good during
October
but last night wasted way she got into
my hotel room at 2:00 made a nice double
tito's and soda killed it before bed and
this morning I woke up with the most
beautiful dream I've ever had in my life
and I hadn't been dreaming during
October
I've just been sleeping I had a dream
where I was sitting next to everything
you guys ever smoked cigarettes sitting
next to a beautiful woman on a dock
smoking a cigarette and I was enjoying
the cigarette I was getting the buzz
from the nicotine in the in the dream
I'm getting the buzz from the NIC team
here pulling it hardest and we're
recapping all my dreams from the night
me and her like like work this is our
wrap right and we've did a great show we
had a bunch of dreams we robbed a bank
we had two guests we had to organize all
my pants from trip flip we had all these
things and then at the end she says she
goes want one more cigarette and I went
yeah and I and I knew this guy wasn't
gonna smoke again but I just hit it
really hard and then I said you know has
a rebel pulse I haven't kissed I haven't
kissed someone who smoked a cigarette so
long I wonder if I can taste it
and she said I don't know we should try
kissing and I want
okay and we started kissing I woke up
and I went what a beautiful way to start
my day I literally was like I'm back
baby
and I and I was like splashing water on
the face time to go to Sirius XM
we got a long day bman try to
strap it on big boy
we're back with the show Burt what were
you just about to ask me about my
drinking so when you talk about drinking
again
yeah what part do you miss cuz I'll tell
you the parts that I exactly
okay go I miss this I miss this Nicky
when someone walks in a room like you're
drinking at the Comedy Cellar back table
I miss seeing someone going kind of like
rocking out like feeling the music and
just excited I missed that you don't get
we you don't get weed you don't get from
weed like that little bit I will find
certain times that it helps me but it's
that it's different with drinking it
just you know what I finished Joe
Rogan's podcast and I stole kombucha
from his fridge right afterwards cuz
they get so much and I grabbed one of
the alcoholic ones and I chugged it in
the car and I got like one drink drunk
and I laugh and my friend who's sober
was driving me and she goes oh my god
Nikki should Carlisle she's like that's
alcoholic and I was like oh my god and I
go I'm just gonna enjoy this I turned
the music I was like I get to be drunk
for the first seven years and probably
the last time and I I have the best time
just like singing to music that's the
drunk I miss Burt you don't miss that
you don't my favorite drunk is family's
asleep I'm in the man cave and I'm gonna
I'm gonna put I'm gonna put the lights
out I'm gonna light some candles I'm
gonna get my speedo maybe a cowboy hat
and I'm gonna just go through the entire
Smiths catalog that's and listen to the
Smiths get weird as goes downstairs
my wife my wife came out one time and I
I had watched a movie about the about
the about the the New Age when New Age
came to Britain yeah and I just got and
I was obsessed I'm on repeat I must have
listened a hundred times to the Talking
Heads one of their first one of the
forget which one it was
serial killer it really is yeah that's
the my favorite kind of drunk okay
getting weird by yourself yeah getting
weird by I do miss the shades and
drinking by myself and alienating all my
friends such a problem with drinking
that the things you miss get real they
they're not even fun weird they're like
they're just sad when I miss like waking
up in the hospital and then proving to
myself it won't happen again
you're always like because what would
happen right now if you had a drink what
what would would become of your day what
are you drinks later I mean I wouldn't
stop I would end up finding cocaine and
then now we're just yeah that's the
problem the lining of the prostitute
yeah wasting my money and you got
rejected at a glory hole yes to a glory
allure glory hole the clock on memorial
how do you did they flick it what
happened
[Laughter]
going to a glory hole in the first place
start by where it's at I'd love the
apartment getting rejected
you got you got to come over after that
I know you were feeling sad yeah okay so
what led you there I don't know I've
just been real horned up lately and
fulfill what you wanted in that right
right and and and more than like with
the drinking thing like I don't miss
getting drunk I miss like waking up in a
bag of trash you know like I
miss like the crazy chaos walking in and
having some you know like six four
dominican guy hate my dick let's do this
like that was what like got me off
rather than like I like that too I like
weird experiencing of me trying to get a
blowjob all the guys mopping up come in
the stall next to me beautiful so you go
in sorry wait how do you know that this
exists is there like an app or alike now
you like cruise around you go just walk
around looking like yeah sorry sir
that's an eye hole oh my god yeah how do
you just know people are like
[Laughter]
when I walk by when mm-hmm so I went in
I kind of looked around store right like
in the back of a store all the porno
shop you see in the back these
stole porn store it's like a Best Buy so
I went in and you know I thought this
guy was whatever and then I was standing
what guy is whatever where the guys see
they stand outside the stalls and you
gotta kind of like look and be like give
like a look-alike what's up
cut to a sketch of me going so do we in
line for just pops out of a hole so you
know who the guy is so they're what's
isn't it supposed to be like you don't
know who it is go into a thing and
there's just you know a treat waiting
for you but then other times you you
make eye contact do you want to
the whole aspect because it's like smell
of cedar like I just you want to you
want to like size him up like you want
to smell I'm not a heathen you know the
wall does seem stupid then yeah wall
separation it's kind of nice because
once it's over it's over half an inch
means a lot to me oh I'd be using that
excuse the whole time look this is a
thick do is you should start lobbying to
put glory holes in the voting booths or
glory I wish the wall was just this see
each other you're not it's it's it's a
father's you can't kneel you don't have
to kneel there's a little chair and
perfect the massage chairs that you sit
in in the mall forward that would be a
good blowjob oh yeah yeah it would
because okay what do you have that porn
Oh
milking calm milkings like it's like a
glory hole but you're laying on your
stomach and a woman's just underneath
just milking
yeah wait wait I have a dream that I go
to a sauna and I sit in underneath
there's someone eating me out that's my
dream yeah like I want my dream I mean
you mean Lana no reality yeah yeah
have that old that's what I mean like a
sauna place I was in a sauna in in Miami
they when used to stay across the street
in one of the places that a sauna in
there and Leanne was coming to visit me
she was pregnant with ila and I walked
into the sauna and this girl walks in
totally naked into the sauna I have
shorts on totally naked
but with um she'll top adidas on like
shoes yeah and no socks and she was like
that's great - ha shake you don't have
to wear your pants in here and I was
like oh yeah I'm probably gonna just
wear my pants she's like why I'm not
wearing clothes and I was like cool and
we're sitting there for a while and I'm
so uncomfortable she's like do have a
room here and I was like Jesus and I
just was I was so creeped out that she
wasn't wearing socks and I just got out
it was like oh my god
by the way but there's nothing better
than having sonic Hawk sonic Hawk is
what sonica sonic hawk are you serious
sonic sonic is basically when
you're just you're in a sauna for like
30 minutes yeah and your dick all the
blood just is going everywhere and your
dick is just huge click you get clicks
on a click and it does get like a little
swollen and it's like the time like
you're soaking up all the wait wait can
PS this is not a plug but that vibrator
that you recommended me the womanizer
yet has changed my life thank you it is
a fleshlight for your click it's crazy
suction yeah it's it goes are you it's
amazing
the great it's like it's changed the
game with Oregon yes I didn't know I I
can squirt I didn't know until I had the
woman is a womanizer
I'm afraid that I'd get this for my wife
and then gets up myself out of the game
oh no no it's different it's a different
feeling can learn from it I'm talking
about this on stage like yeah if you go
down on us stop the rubbing your face in
it or whatever you suck whispering a
secret womanizer right now that you can
use it's j-20 but yeah all caps Jayde
you know why because she commented on
one of my Instagram photos like get the
womanizer so I just texted them directly
like damn them directly I was like send
me one I'll review it on my story
Oh Mike so they sent me one and it's
been because you know what it is it
doesn't feel like it goes inside you you
feel like you're it in a weird
way the white thing yeah but get the
black or red I regret getting the white
one cuz it's to clinical looking for
like futuristic you guys are starlit yes
woman eyes are preemie it looks like Oh
cuz you want to go womanizer premium I
like excited thinking about this like
sex toys always tried to do that and
she's like why would I do that when
you're here and I'm like I don't know
maybe for when I'm not here because you
know what it is it happens quickly too
and then I have a goal so I giggle it is
a different kind of orgasm than you've
experienced sorry if you don't know this
kind of sorry so it took me a while to
figure out how to use it I was like well
like it's it's the vagina is not user
friendly I got infused by it and
having one and try to figure it out the
only manual is passive aggression
there's tools yeah wait I'm just finding
that does seem to just like creep from a
crevice yeah you know when like you look
at a cave wall and it's just like
there's exactly what it's like it's very
confusing but the womanizer you
definitely need to I agree and I'm like
hey you guys send me two more because I
want to give one to my mom and my sister
so it makes sense yeah well I watched a
video that talked to you about how to
eat like it was an essential video
by nina hartley she's like an old
pornstar about how to eat and I
remember watching it and she said treat
the clit like you would your tiny penis
if your penis was very tiny what you
would want done to it do exactly that
and it's an insane thing to say because
guys don't blow job it is a tiny blow
job that you get it's like uh huh yep
like literally like that I yeah it's
really it's so that's my advice to you
if you go down on a girl this weekend
just latch onto that thing like a
barnacle on an old boat and don't let go
till the captain sprays you off
[Music]
you